[Music]
while it might seem a little extreme to
put a whole data center at the bottom of
the ocean data centers strike at the
core of what this company does and what
Microsoft does it is a kind of a far-out
idea but highly relevant to the future
and as we look at the world today we see
many more interactive applications
things like AR and VR in order to really
address that and provide this more
responsive cloud one of the things that
we look at is bringing the cloud closer
to our customers project Natick not only
is it exercising green tech but it's
also an exercise in whether we can get
to a mass production concept the
leadership in offshore renewable energy
is really in Europe Scotland is also
home to the European marine energy
center which is the largest test site in
the world for offshore renewable
energies like tide and wave energy
putting something the ocean is something
that we don't really have a whole lot of
experience with for this deployment
we're working with a company called
naval group of France getting that group
of engineers in the same room with our
group of engineers you know there were
ideas that came up and that spur an idea
in someone else and it really led us to
get to the design that we right now the
vessel was built as two pieces there's
an external shell which is a pressure
vessel itself and then an internal
payload
so this data center runs entirely off
renewable energy our vessel is powered
by a combination of solar power wind
power and offshore tidal and wave energy
[Music]
this is a true lights-out data center
people have been wanting to design such
a data center for the last decades that
I get involved in the business and this
is the very first one that I've actually
seen that we're gonna do it and we'll
see what happens so we had around 35
people on the sea diverts and off a
vehicle we had the team taking all the
electricity to make sure that the
connection were just perfect
and I think we can move
officially never group says on the
infrastructure side it's okay to proceed
with deployment the Natick data center
by no means replaces those big data
centers have you come to know
just being able to order precisely the
amount of data center capacity you need
and have it delivered to you that is the
product concept that we dream about with
project name
[Music]
you